ايطاليا تعلن روتوخها لقد حان وقت التفاوض
مع روسيا وامريكا تتدخل في وساطه السعوديه
بشان الازمه الاوكرانيه وكيف تعلق املها
على الرياض فهل يفعلها ال سعود هذه المره
بوتين يدخل نوعا اخر من مفترسات المحيط
الى الحرب واشنطن تورط بلغاريا وكوريا
الجنوبيه امام الدب الروسي وبين الجو
والبحر حرب مسيرات تلهب الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وموسكو تتوعد الامارات تستعرض
بسخائها للاوكرانيين فماذا عن فلسطين يا
ابناء زايد والصين تقول كلمتها الاخيره في
وجه الولايات المتحده واسرائيل تقترب خطوه
اخرى من السعوديه والجزائر تشهر رايه
التحدي وتحذر الغرب من التدخل في النيجر
طنين المسيراتي يلهب المعارك جوا وبحرا لا
صوت يعلو فوق صوت المسيرات التي قالت فتيل
المعارك على نحو غير مسبوق في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهنا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن تدمير ثلاث مسيرات بحريه
اوكرانيه حاولت مهاجمه سفن نقل مدنيه
الروسيه متجهه الى مضيق البوسفور وما هذه
الا البدايه لقائمه معارك لا تنتهي من
المسيره فبحسب وسائل اعلام امريكيه فقد
لاجئت القوات الاوكرانيه الى تطوير مسيرات
بحريه محليه الصنع تسمح بمهاجمه ومراقبه
الجيش الروسي في البحر الاسود وشبه جزيره
القرم وقد تم استخدام هذه الزوارق في
هجومين حتى الان وهنا المصدر يتحدث وزاره
الدفاع الروسي قالت بان احبطت هجوما
اوكرانيا استعملت فيه اوكرانيا ما يسمى
بالزوارق المسيره بغرض استهداف السفن
حربيه للجيش الروسي وفي كل مره ترد موسكو
بتدميره مصنع لهذه المسيرات اذا فسترد على
هذا الهجوم الاخير مهلا مهلا فحرب مسيرات
بدات للتو ولم يمضي عليها الا الوقت
القليل لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن انها
كانت قد احبطت محاولته هجوم من قبل نظام
لاستهداف مواقع في مدينه موسكو بواسطه
طائرات بدون طيار لكن انظمه الدفاع الجوي
ووسائل الحرب الالكترونيه كانت لها
بالمرصاد بحسب الوزاره الروسيه فيا لها من
وسائل
لاي مجال العدو لتظهر المسيره الاوكرانيه
من جديد في اجواء موسكو لتستهدف منطقه
تجاريه وهنا ردت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
بان استهداف ابراج موسكو سيتي يشبه احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مشيره الى انها منشاه مدنيه
واستهدافها عمل ارهابي الرد الاوكراني لا
يتاخر هذه المره باعلان المستشار للرئيس
الاوكراني ان موسكو يجب ان تعتاد بسرعه
على ما وصفها بالحرب الشامله التي ستنتقل
قريبا الى مناطقها فعن اي حرب شامله يتحدث
هل تكفي المسيرات لشان حرب على روسيا نترك
لكم الاجابه بينما نعرض عليكم المصدر
التي قامت بمقارنه هذه الهجمات على موسكو
سيتي في العاصمه الروسيه مع هجمات من احدى
عشر سبتمبر
على نيويورك قال مستشار للرئيس الاوكراني
ان موسكو يجب ان تعتاد وبسرعه على ما
وصفها بالحرب الشامله التي ستنتقل قريبا
الى مناطقها ولنكمل حيث افادت صحيفه
نيويورك بان اوكرانيا تسعى لزياده صناعه
الطائره المسيره لضرب الاراضي الروسيه
وهنا كشفت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن
توقيع اتفاقيه مع شركه بايكر ماكينه
التركيه المتخصصه في تقنيات الطائرات
المسيره والمنتجه لمسيره بمقدار على انشاء
مركز في اوكرانيا لصيانه المسيرات فكيف
سيرد بوتين على حلفائه الاتراك ولا زلنا
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه ووسط كل تلك
المعارك وهنا اعلن الجيش الاوكراني احباط
محاوله قامت بها مجموعه الروسيه لاقتحام
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من الحدود الشماليه في
منطقه شيرن هاف وقالت انه تم نشر قوه
احتياط من حرس الحدود والقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في المنطقه في المقابل قالت
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان
الاسطول الروسي عزز من وجود سفنه الجاهزه
للمهام القتاليه في البحر الاسود مضيفه ان
هناك سفينتين وغواصه عسكريه روسيه لاداء
هذه المهمه واشارت قياده العمليات
الاوكرانيه الى ان 16 صاروخا من نوع
اصبحت جاهزه للاطلاق ليبدا الغرب
بالاعتراف رسميا بقوه روسيا حيث قالت
صحيفه البريطانيه ان موسكو تم ادوات
تمكنها من احداث الفوضى في الدول الغربيه
وهي قادره على اظهار مفاجات في الحرب على
اوكرانيا بحسب الصحيفه بينما ردخت ايطاليا
للامر الواقع حين اعرب وزير الدفاع
الايطالي جويدو كروسيتو عن استعداده
للتفاوض مع روسيا والصين واي طرف اخر من
اجل تحقيق سلام عادل في اوكرانيا فهل حان
وقت جنوح الغرب للتفاوض يا هؤلاء وعلى ذكر
المفاوضات قال مسؤولون امريكيون انه من
المتوقع ان يحضر مستشار الامن القومي
محادثه سلام بشان الازمه الاوكرانيه من
المقرر عقدها الاسبوع المقبل في السعوديه
وذلك بحسب شبكه سي ان ان والتي اضافت ان
اوكرانيا تامل ان تعمل المحادثه على تحديد
المبادئ المشتركه لانهاء الحرب وكما
يقولها الخليجيون اخيرا قالها نعم كيف
تامل في التفاوض فهل يتركها الغرب تجلس
على الطاوله لكن لا يبدو بان امريكا مقت
نعه بالتفاوض ها هو المستشار السابق في
وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكي يؤكد ان الولايات المتحده تريد
هدنه في اوكرانيا لان هذا سيمنحهم الفرصه
للراحه واعاده تسليح القوات الاوكرانيه
لضرب روسيا مره اخرى مشيرا الى ان روسيا
لن توافق على هذه الشروط لانها تنتصر بثقه
في ساحه المعركه واما صحيفه
بان الولايات المتحده ابرمت صفقات مع كل
من بلغاريا وكوريا الجنوبيه وتتفاوض مع
اليابان لتوريد ذخائر عيار 155
وهنا تدخل هذه الدول في ورطه بسبب التعدي
على خطوط موسكو الحمراء وهي لها من ورطه
هذه الدول اصبحت بين مطرقه روسيا وسندان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي سياق
المساعدات ارسلت الاماره باخره تحمل على
متنها 250 طرنا من المساعدات الاغاثيه الى
اوكرانيا وفق ما افادت وكاله الانباء
الاماراتيه وامام لكن انسي ابناء زايد بان
اشقائهم في فلسطين هم احق بتلك المساعدات
الاحداث والتطورات قالت وزاره الدفاع
الصينيه انها قدمت احتجاجات شديده الله
الولايات المتحده حول حزمه مساعدات من
الاسلحه قدمتها لتايوان وذكر متحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع الصينيه في بيان ان جيش
التحرير الشعبي الاهتماما وثيقا بالوضع في
مضيق تايوان ويبقى دائما في حاله تاهب
القصوى تحدث وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي عن
التقدم في الاتصالات بين الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه لابرام صفقه
امنيه
وقال كوهن في مقابله مع قناه انثى العبريه
ان اسرائيل حاليا اقرب من اي وقت مضى من
اتفاق سلام مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي ان روسيا
والجزائر ملتزمه باتباع سياسه خارجيه
مستقله والدفاع عن مصالحهما واكد استعداد
موسكو للمساعده بتعزيز القدرات القتاليه
للقوات الجزائريه من جهتها قالت وزاره
الشؤون الخارجيه الجزائريه في بيان ان
الجزائر تجدد تمسكها بضروره عوده النظام
الدستوري في النيجر مقتضيات صياده القانون
ودعمها للسيد محمد بازون بصفته الرئيس
الشرعي محذره من نوايا تدخل العسكري
الاجنبي في هذا البلد فيما دخلت مالي
وبوركينا فاسو على خط الازمه واعلنت
دعمهما الصريح للانقلابيين في النيجر
ملوحتين بالتدخل العسكري في حال ارسال اي
قوات غربيه ومنذ بدايه الانقلاب في النيجر
تتعرض البلاد الى ضغوط اقتصاديه من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول ايكواس في محاوله
لاعاده الرئيس محمد بازومي الى سده
الرئاسه
[موسيقى]